You know, on your phone, the buttons are
laid out 1 to 3 on the top? Have
you ever thought about actually why
they're like that? It's not, it's not a
chance at all, like a lot of work
back in the 50s went into deciding how
phones should look; and it actually was
all decided just in this paper
really.
This is a technical report from Bell
Labs, they were deciding what the phone
should look like. Now that rotary dials
were no longer the only way to dial a
phone number, as touch-tone came in to
things, they had the opportunity to design
what a push-button phone should look
like, because no one had done it before.
(Brady: Some of our younger viewers
might not be familiar
with it)
- I'm not familiar with it!
(Brady: Didn't you ever live in a house with a rotary?)
No, of course I didn't!
- (Brady: I did!)
- Well...that tells us
something about our ages, doesn't it?
And you stick your finger in the hole and
then you can, like you have to drag the
dial all the way round and then let it
go and it goes back, and you have to do
that for every phone number. But in the,
in the 50s they were realising they had
the technology to mean you didn't have
to do that anymore, and you could actually
just press buttons to get tones and to
make the, to make the phone calls to dial
out; and so they were making a phone with
buttons on it. The first thing they
thought was that they could um they
could just put the buttons in the same
places where all the dials were. Well,
yeah it's okay, people can use it, but it
doesn't hav- there's no reason it has
to be like that so why, why keep it like
that? Why not take the opportunity to
have a bit of fun and be creative with
things? Basically they don't know if this
is the best design either, this is just a
design that people are used to. What if
there's another design out there that
people are better at using? So they
thought, this is one design - but we can
have a whole, a whole host of other ways we
can design, we can design the number
layouts. And so here we have a set of the
designs they tried out. So this one is
the, this is like how calculators are
laid out. Or in this paper they refer to
adding machines. Or like laying them out
like a like a brick wall I guess? I don't
know, or like a bowling alley or
something like that. That one's quite
insane, isn't it? Yeah, kind of heading up
the machine. I mean who knows what they
were thinking - like I said they just had
the opportunity to try anything out. But
you do have to remember at this point,
like, the touch-tone phone, the touch-tone
phone wasn't a common - it wasn't a common
thing. Like it may seem to you and I that
obviously they should use like a 3x3
grid, but like only people who had used
adding machines and calculators at that
time had, had any experience of how
numbers should be laid out; it's not a
common thing. They got loads of people in
from the labs
and they just got people in and made
them dial phone numbers, it was as simple
as, as that. They were very good at
testing human factors at Bell Labs. I'll
tell you, like a cool story. They were
trying to work out how long the phone
cord should be, and like and the copper
in the cord is quite expensive, so they
wanted to try and work out how short
they could make it; and the way they did
that, they - the person in charge of like
the human factors department, went into
everyone's rooms and started cutting the
cable shorter and shorter and shorter
until someone went "hang on what's
happening here?" and then at that point
they were like, okay that's the shortest it
can probably go. They - like they were
really good at finding, doing experiments
to find the answers to these things. Yeah,
so they got people in and they got
people to just dial phone numbers on all
of these different different layouts. And
they would, they were testing for how
quickly they could do it, and how often
they made errors when they were doing it.
(Brady: What'd they find? What happened?)
- Gasp, well I think you
know the ending, because you know what a
phone looks like now. But they, they kind of
whittled these ones down and they came
up with these five final designs. You can
see they're doing, they're interesting
names. They've called this one here
speedometer, which is quite funny. Yeah and so
you can see they're they're trying to
test how quickly they go, how quickly
people can type on them, like the
percentage of errors that people make on
them and, and how people preferred them.
And you can see there's this, this kind
of a trade-off here. So like one of the,
one of the slowest ones was actually one
of the most accurate ones; and that's a
common thing we know, if you go slower
you're more likely to be accurate. But
actually there was no massive difference
in the, in the timing and the
errors. And so what they did was they
started to look at the people - at
people's preference and people's - which
ones people hated the most. And because
there was not much of a difference, what
they went with was the one that would,
just for engineering reasons they say,
they went with this the, the telephone
layout. What's perhaps the most
interesting thing I think is that they
did compare the thing we're calling
the telephone layout and the calculator
layout and they found that the
calculator layout was, was slower than the
telephone layout. This paper, this is from
1955 so five years prior to that one, and
they're trying to work out - they're still,
they're starting to think about the
buttons. They're not testing the actual
machines yet, what they're doing in this
paper is giving people blank layouts. So
they're giving, they're giving people
this, they're just they're just giving
people a booklet that just has this on
it and then they say to people, "you have
to put the numbers naught to nine in
that grid - how are you going to do it?". And
again remember people haven't seen a
telephone before, and few people have
used a calculator before. And it turns
out when people fill this in, 55%
of people chose the phone layout. 55% of
people went, well obviously it should go
like this. You know, you start counting
from the left-hand side. Only 8%
of people did the; 8% of people
did the calculator layout. 7% of
people did this fairly peculiar layout. So
they started with 1, yeah obviously
they start with 1, but then what they
did was they started to fill them in
vertically like this which is just;
baffles me. I'm not sure why that's the
most sensible way to do it. Like I said
it's something - you use a telephone
so often that you just, you just don't really think
about why on Earth it should be like that.
Just, because you've been perhaps brought
up with it you just, like obviously
that's how numbers are laid out. But
there was a time when people didn't know
how numbers should be laid out and so
they had to do all of this type of
experimentation
to work it out. And it's, it's, it's really,
it's a really good example of how human
factors matters in design. You know, they
assumed this, this this rotary would be
the best but it didn't end up being that
way. And because of what they learnt from
experiments we now have a telephone
that's optimally designed for us.
We'd like to thank audible.com for
supporting this video. Audible has a huge
range, I think it's something like
150,000 audiobooks you can download. And
you can download one for free if you go
to audible.com/numberphile. After
watching this video you might want to
check out a book about Alexander Graham Bell
or something about inventions; or
check out one of my all-time favourite
books,
it's called The Mote in God's Eye and
it's about sort of first contact with an
alien civilisation and - I could talk
about it for hours, it's really cool and
really clever. So thanks to audible.com
for their support of us and if you do
want to go and have a look, maybe sign up
and get that free book, you're probably
doing us a favour as well. That's all for
now, see you next time.
[Extra:] But you have to,
you have to balance up like accuracy
with speed; like the ideal number
entry interface, in terms of making like
the most accurate one, might be one with
the numbers spaced like, like a foot
apart or something like that. So you have
to physically move to press the buttons.
Like, that would be quite accurate
probably, but it would be incredibly slow
and really annoying.